So now we have, from the last quiz, the equation, negative x squared over 8 plus
4 x minus 14 equals 0. We already saw though that these two equations, which we
know both describe our parabola here, are equivalent to one another. So that
means, we know that negative x squared over 8 plus 4 x minus 14 is equal to
negative 1 8th times x minus 4 times x minus 28. So, we can set the right-hand
side of this equation equal to zero through simple substitution. Wonderful, now
we have another equation. This one, however, is actually pretty easy to solve if
we think of a little trick. First things first, we're going to simplify. Can you
think of a really, really easy way to simplify this? In particular, I'd really
love to get rid of this factor of negative 1 8th. The first thing I'd like you
to tell me is what we can do to both sides of this equation to get rid of this
factor of negative 1 8th. In this little blue box, please write some sort of
operator and then a number. Plus, minus, multiply or divide, and then whatever
number you think we should do that with. Once you figure out how to get rid of
this negative 1 8th, I'd like you to write the new version of the equation in
this box right here. So, the equation I want here is just the equation that we
have after we get rid of that factor of negative 1 8th.